opposers this can't wait Bill Cosby was
just found guilty in a second trial
today after the first one ended in a
deadlocked jury good justice served but
I am a little worried about the
precedent that sets this Cosby thing
happened pretty quickly nearly 60
accusers spanning 43 years dozens of his
victims willing to testify the five of
them the court allowed to talk and two
full trials to get justice for this one
woman Wow it's just that easy Trump you
better watch out
your allegations are starting to
approach those same numbers you better
lawyer up some more because the judicial
system starts listening to women this
swiftly what's next society listening to
women believing them is this what
justice feels like opposers are there
any three words more exciting than click
and subscribe
yes Hillary shot Lincoln subscribe now
and find out the truth they don't want
you to know and by day I mean losers
looking for YouTube handouts without
clicking subscribe do it